>>Kate Crawford: There is no quick
technical fix to bias.
It’s really tempting to want to think that
there’s going to be some type of silver-bullet
solution that we can just tweak our algorithms
or, you know, use different sorts of training
data sets, or try to boost
signal in particular ways.
The problem of this is that it really doesn’t
look to the deep social and historical issues
that human data is made from.
(music)
Host: You’re listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast.
A show that brings you closer to the cutting-edge
of technology research and the scientists
behind it.
I’m your host Gretchen Huizinga.
Artificial intelligence has captured our imagination
and made many things we would have thought
impossible only a few years ago
seem commonplace today.
But AI has also raised some challenging
issues for society writ large.
Enter Dr. Kate Crawford, a principal researcher
at the New York City lab of Microsoft Research.
Dr. Crawford, along with an illustrious group
of colleagues in computer science, engineering,
social science, business and law, has dedicated
her research to addressing the social implications
of AI, including big topics like bias, labor
and automation, rights and liberties
and ethics and governance.
Today, Dr. Crawford talks about both the promises
and the problems of AI, why when it comes
to data, bigger isn’t necessarily better,
and how even in an era of increasingly complex
technological advances, we can adopt AI design
principles that empower people to shape their
technical tools in ways they would
like to use them most.
That and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast.
(music)
Host: Welcome Kate Crawford to the podcast.
Great to have you here with us
from New York City.
Kate Crawford: Thank you so much Gretchen.
It’s a pleasure to be here.
Host: So, you’re in the, as we’ve said,
New York City lab of Microsoft Research.
What goes on in the Big Apple?
Kate Crawford: Ahhh!
So much.
It’s a city that doesn’t sleep when research
is concerned.
Look, there’s so much going on here.
It is actually — we a have an abundance
of exciting research initiatives.
Obviously here, we have the Microsoft Research
New York office.
In here, we have really sort of four groups
writ large.
We have a really fantastic machine learning
group.
We have a computational social science group.
We have an algorithmic economics group.
And we have the FATE group, which is a group
that I co-founded with my colleagues Hannah
Wallach and Fernando Diaz, and it stands for
fairness, accountability, transparency and ethics.
And that group is coming into
its third year now.
We really, early on, saw that there were going
to be some real concerns around insuring that
large-scale, decision-making systems were
producing fair results and fair predictions,
and we also needed to start thinking much
more about accountability for decision-making;
particularly in relation to machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
And, of course, ethics, which is a very broad
term that can mean all sorts of things.
For us, it means really looking at how people
are affected by a whole range of technologies
that are now touching our lives, be that in
criminal justice or education or in healthcare.
So that was the reason we formed the FATE
group here in New York.
In addition to what’s happening here at
MSR NYC, there are also other groups.
There’s Data and Society which is headed by
danah boyd, just around the corner from this building.
And then at NYU, we have a brand-new research
institute that I co-founded with Meredith
Whitaker, called the AI Now Institute.
And that’s the first university institute to focus
on the social implications of artificial intelligence.
So, there’s a lot going on in
New York right now.
Host: I’ll say.
You know, I want to ask you some specific
questions about a couple of those things that
you mentioned, but drill in a little bit on
what computational social science means.
Kate Crawford: Yeah.
That group is headed by Duncan Watts and realistically,
they are looking at large-scale data to try
and make sense of particular types of patterns.
So, what can you learn about how a city is working
when you look at traffic flows, for example.
What are the ways in which you could contextualize
people’s search information in order to
give them different types of
data that could help.
I mean there are lots of things that the CSS
group does here in New York.
Host: Well let’s go back to FATE, because
that’s kind of a big interest of yours right now.
Fairness, accountability,
transparency and ethics.
Kate Crawford: Yeah.
Host: And you sort of gave us an overview of why
you started the group and it’s fairly nascent.
Is it having an impact already?
Is it having any impact that you hoped for
in the high-tech industry?
Kate Crawford: Absolutely.
We’ve been really thrilled.
I mean, even though it’s only 3 years old,
in some ways, that’s actually quite established
for thinking about these issues.
I’ve been as a researcher focusing on questions
around fairness and due-process in sort of
large-scale data systems and machine learning
for over ten years.
But it’s really only been in the last 18
months or so that we’ve seen this huge uptick
in interest across both academia and industry.
So, we’re starting to see algorithmic accountability
groups emerge in kind of the key technology
companies here in the US.
We also have conferences like the FAT/ML conference.
Which stands for fairness, accountability
and transparency, you guessed it.
Which has now is now become a blockbuster hit.
It actually taking place here in New York
City in just two weeks to a full house and
an extensive waiting list.
So, it’s really actually taking off.
But we are also seeing it really start to
have impact within Microsoft itself.
I mean, here, Hannah and myself for example,
and various product groups who are coming
up with questions where they think a system
might produce say a discriminatory output,
what should they do?
Or they might have concerns with the data
that a system has been trained on.
What sorts of questions might you want to ask?
Including all the way through to, what are the
big policy questions that we need to ask here.
And we’re doing things like speaking to
the European Commission, to the UN, etc.
So, um, for a small group, it’s just four
of us, I think it’s already having a pretty
outsized impact.
Host: Interesting that you say you’ve been
doing this for about ten years, which I think
is surprising to a lot of people, with machine
learning coming to the forefront now.
Why, do you think, only in the last 18 months
have we seen an uptick?
Kate Crawford: I think it has a lot to do
with scale.
I mean what’s particularly interesting to
me is that just in the last actually about
three months, we’ve seen leaders from major
technology companies including Satya Nadella,
including one of the co-founders of Deep Mind,
Mustafa Suleyman, and the head of Google AI,
all say that fairness and bias were the key
challenges for the next five years.
So, it’s gone from being something that
was a relatively bespoke concern, shall we say,
to becoming front-of-mind for all of the sort
of leaders of the major technology companies.
And I think the reason why, and certainly
the reason that Mustafa gave when he was sort
of making his statement about this, is because
if you have a system that’s producing a
discriminatory result say, for example, in
a search, or in ads, that is affecting a billion
to two billion users a day, easily.
So, at that scale, that can be extremely costly
and extremely dangerous for the people who
are subject to those decisions.
So, I think, in that sense, it’s really
a question of how many people can be affected
by these sorts of systems,
given their truly vast reach.
(music)
Host: You recently gave a talk at the NIPS conference
— Neural Information Processing Systems.
And the topic was called
The Trouble with Bias.
What is the trouble with bias, Kate?
Kate Crawford: Well, NIPS is an amazing conference,
I should say, out of the gate.
It was a real honor to speak there.
It is, in fact, the largest machine learning
conference in the world.
I was speaking in this room as the sort of
opening keynote to around 8,000 people, so
it kind of felt like being at a Van Halen
concert or something extremely stadium rock.
It was extraordinary to see.
But I was really interested to talk about
what’s been happening with this concept
of bias.
And I looked at, particularly, some of the
cases that we’ve seen emerge that have been
interesting to researchers.
So, for example, everything from, if you do
a search in Bing or in Google, for “CEO”
and you do an image search, you’ll find
a lot of images of white men in suits.
And, depending on which way the algorithm
is blowing that day, the first woman that
you’ll see is, quite often, CEO Barbie.
So, it raises very troubling questions about
how we represent a gender.
And then of course, there are a whole series
of studies coming out now, looking at how
we represent race.
And here we can look at anything from the
way that a training data set like Labeled
Faces in the Wild is around 79% male and 84%
white, so they’re the sorts of populations
that systems that are trained on Labeled Faces
in the Wild will perform best for.
So, that’s in the space of facial recognition.
But what I was talking about at NIPS was,
really sharing brand new research that I’ve
been working on with Solon Barocas at Cornell
and Hannah Wallach here at Microsoft Research
and Aaron Shapiro at U Penn, where we’re
looking at the way that bias in computer science
has traditionally been looked at.
And basically, the way that it’s been studied
so far, we did a big analysis of all of the
papers, is that it really looks at the types
of harms that cause a type of economic,
or what we call allocative, harm.
So, it means that a system is determined to
be biased if you don’t get a job or if it
decides that you don’t get bail or if you
can’t get access to credit.
But there’s a whole range of other harms
which we call representational harms, which
doesn’t mean that you don’t necessarily
get a job, but it might mean that it’s just
a denigration of a particular category or community.
Host: Let’s talk for a minute about the
data sets that actually train our AI models.
As far as the data goes, we’re often told
that bigger is better.
But what you just said, suggests this might
not be the case.
Can you explain how bigger data isn’t necessarily
better data?
Kate Crawford: Yeah, I mean there has been
I think this perception, for some time now,
that the more data we have,
the more representative it is.
But that’s simply not the case.
If you are over-sampling from a particular
population, we could think about here, you
know, say, for example, Twitter data.
There was a period, so five years ago, when
people really thought Twitter data was going
to be the best way to understand what was happening
during a natural disaster or humanitarian crisis.
But it was very, very clear, from early on,
and certainly in some work that I was doing
many years ago, that showed just how skewed
the demographics are of people who were using
Twitter at that time, let alone people who
have access to smartphones.
So, depending where you in the world, that
means it’s not particularly a very reliable signal.
So, even if you have hundreds of thousands
of data points, if all of those data points
are being drawn from affluent populations,
who live in urban centers, then you’re only
seeing one part of the picture and it’s
going to be extremely difficult for you to
extrapolate from that.
And there are very, sort of, related problems
happening with training data right now.
Training data is you know, often comes from
sets that have hundreds of thousands, if not
millions, of particular items within them.
But if they are very particularly sampled
from an already skewed pool, then that’s
going to still produce results.
I mean, there have been some really, you know,
interesting examples I think that we can look
at here. And they come from
all sorts of interesting places.
In the case of you know criminal justice,
there’s been a lot of controversy around
the use of the Compass Risk Assessment System,
which essentially tries to predict a risk
score for whether or not somebody will re-offend
as a violent criminal.
But of course, it’s, you know, trained on
data that is historical crime data.
And again, many criminologists and social
scientists point to the fact that there is
a long history of racist policing in the US.
So, if you’re already coming from a baseline
where people of color and low-income communities
are far more likely to be stopped by the police,
to be arrested by the police, and be generally
surveilled, they will be over-represented
in those samples.
And then if you’re training a system on that
data, how do you actually accommodate that?
These are really hard questions and I think
what I’ve certainly learned from looking
at these questions as a researcher is that
there is no quick technical fix to bias.
It’s really tempting to want to think that
there’s going to be some type of silver-bullet
solution, that we can just tweak our algorithms
or use different sorts of training data sets
or try to boost signal in particular ways.
The problem of this is that it really doesn’t
look to the deep social and historical issues
that human data is made from.
That essentially, data reflects our human
history.
And our human history itself has many, many
instances of bias.
So, I think what’s so interesting, and when
I talk about the trouble with bias, is that
I think, particularly in computer science,
we tend to scope the problem too narrowly
and to think of it purely as something we
can address technically.
I think it’s incredibly important that we
understand it as a socio-technical problem.
That means addressing these sorts of issues
very much in an interdisciplinary context.
So, if you’re designing a system that is
doing anything to do with criminal justice
system, you should be working side-by-side
with people who have been doing the most important
work in those fields.
This pertains to every one of the domains
of healthcare, education, criminal justice,
policing, you name it.
We have area experts who I think have just
been, to this point, kind of left out of those
development cycles, and we really need them
in the room.
Host: Well, I think there’s been a misconception,
first of all that data doesn’t lie.
And it can if you have you know, specific
populations that you’re only representing.
But also, this idea of the sort of “separation
of church and state” between technology
and the humanities,
or technology and social science.
And so, what I’m hearing, not just from
you but over and over, is we have to start
talking, cross-pollinating, silo-busting,
whatever you want to call it, to solve some
of these bigger problems, yeah?
Kate Crawford: Absolutely.
I couldn’t agree more.
I mean this was really one of the really big
motivations behind establishing the AI Now
Institute at NYU, is that we realize we really
needed to create a university center that
was inviting people from all disciplines to
come and collaborate on these sorts of questions.
And particularly in terms of issues around,
you know, bias and fairness.
But even more broadly, in terms of things
like labor and automation and the future of work,
right through to what happens when we
start applying machine learning to critical
infrastructure, like the
power grid or to hospitals.
In order to answer any of those questions,
you kind of need a really deep bench of people
from very different disciplines and we ended
up trying to address that by working with
six different faculty incentives
to establish AI Now.
So, it’s a co-production if you will between
computer science, engineering, social science,
business and law, as well as the Center for
Data Science, really because I think you need
all those people to really make it work.
(music)
Host: Let’s switch to another topic for
a bit.
And that is this concept of autonomous experimentation.
With the proliferation of sensors and massive
amounts of data gathering, people may not
be aware much of the time that they are in
fact data and not necessarily with their knowledge
or consent. Can you speak to that?
Kate Crawford: Oh, absolutely.
I mean I should say the autonomous experimentation
research that we’ve been doing here is very
much a collaborative project which has been
work I’ve been doing alongside people like
Hannah Wallach and Fernando Diaz and Sarah
Bird.
And it’s been really fascinating to, essentially
look at how a series of new systems that are
really being deployed far more widely than
people realize, are actually doing forms of
automated experimentation in real-time.
And we were looking at a range of systems
including, say, what happens when you use
a traffic app. You know, just using a mapping
app that’s saying where is the traffic bad?
Where is it good?
The way these systems are working is that
they’re essentially constantly running experiments,
large-scale experiments, often on hundreds
of thousands of people, simultaneously.
And this can be good.
In many cases, it’s for things like you
know, load balancing where people go.
If we all got the same directions to go to,
you know, say, downtown Manhattan from uptown
Manhattan, then the roads would be unusable.
They would be completely congested.
So, you kind of have to load-balance
between different parts.
But what that also means is that some people
will always be allocated to the less ideal
condition set of that experiment and some
of that will be allocated to the ideal condition set.
Which means that you know, you might be getting
the fastest way to get to work that day, and
somebody else will be getting
a slightly slower way.
And now, this sounds absolutely fine when
you’re thinking about you know, perhaps
if you’re just going to work in a few minutes,
either side isn’t going to ruin your day.
But what if you’re going to hospital?
What if you have a sick kid in the back of
your car and it’s really urgent that you
get to a hospital.
How can you say, “No, I really don’t want
to be allocated into the less ideal group”?
Or this could happen as well in health apps.
You know, how can you indicate that, in experimentation,
which has been used to try and, say, make
you jog more or do more exercise, that you’re
somebody who’s recovering from injury or
somebody who has a heart condition.
These are the sorts of issues that really
indicated to us that it’s important that
we start doing more work on feedback mechanisms.
On what are the sorts of consent mechanisms
that we can think about when people are being
allocated into experiments, often without
their knowledge.
This is very common now.
We’re kind of getting used to the fact that AB
experiments at-scale really began with search.
But now they’re really moving and submerging
into much more intimate systems that guide
our everyday lives from anything that you’re
using on your phone about your health or your
engagements with friends, right through to
you know, how you spend your time.
So, how do we start to think about the consent
mechanisms around experimentation?
That was the real motivation behind those
series of ongoing studies.
Host: Well and it does speak to this dichotomy
between self-governance and government regulation.
And because we are in kind of a Wild West
phase of AI, a lot of things haven’t caught up yet.
However, the European Union has the GDPR that
does attempt to address some of these issues.
What is your thinking on whether we go with
our own oversight, “who is watching the
watch dog” kind of thing or invite regulations.
What’s going on in your mind about that?
Kate Crawford: It’s such a good question.
It’s an incredibly complex question and
unfortunately there are no easy answers here.
I mean, certainly GDPR comes into effect in
May this year and I think it’s going to
be extraordinarily interesting to see what
happens as it begins to be rolled out.
Certainly, a lot of the technology companies
have been doing a lot of work to think about
how their products are going to change in
terms of what they’re offering.
But it will also be interesting to see if
it has flow on effects to other parts of the
world like the US and a whole range of other
countries that aren’t covered by GDPR.
Host: Well, the interesting thing for me is
that say, the European Union has it.
It has far-reaching tentacles, right?
It’s not just for Europe.
It’s for anyone who does business with Europe.
And it does as you say represent
a very complex question.
Kate Crawford: It does.
I mean I think about this a lot in terms of
artificial intelligence writ large, and that
term can mean many things.
So, I’m using it here to really refer to
not just sort of machine learning based systems,
but a whole range of other technologies that
fit under the AI banner.
And this is something that is going to have
enormous impacts over the next ten years.
And there’s a lot of attention being paid
to, what are the types of regulatory infrastructures,
what are the types of state and corporate
pressures on these sectors and how is it going
to change the way that people are
judged by these systems?
As we know China has a social credit score.
Some people find this quite a disturbing system,
but there are many things in the US
that are not dissimilar.
So, we’re already moving quite rapidly into
a state where these systems are being used
to have direct impacts on people’s lives.
And I think there’s going to be a lot of
questions that we have to ask about how to
ensure that that is both ethical and,
I think, equitable.
Host: Right.
And that is where, interestingly I think,
some good research could be happening,
both on the technical side and the
social science side, as we address these.
And all of the sort of expertise and disciplines
that you talked that are working in the FATE group.
(music)
Host: So, let’s talk for a second about…
there’s so many questions I want to ask you,
Kate, and this is just not really enough
time. So, I’m coming to New York.
I’m going to get into the bad traffic there
and come see you.
Kate Crawford: Great. Wonderful.
Host: Listen, the overarching question for
me right now is about, how do we take these
big, thorny, prickly, questions… issues,
and start to address them practically?
What are your thoughts on how we can maybe
re-assert or re-capture our “agency” in
what I’d call a get app world?
Kate Crawford: Yeah, I think that’s a really
fascinating question.
I mean what’s interesting, of course, is
how many systems that touch our lives these
days that we don’t even have
a screen interface for. So many,
many major cities, you’re walking down the
street, you know, your face is being recorded.
Your emotions are being predicted based on
your expressions that day.
You know, your geolocation is being tracked
through your phone.
These are all things that don’t involve
any type of permission structure, a screen,
or even you being aware that, you know, your
data and your movements are being ingested
by a particular system.
So, I think my concern is that while more
granular permission-based structures are possible,
urban computing has shifted away from the
devices directly in front of us to be embedded
throughout architectures, throughout streets,
throughout so many systems, that are in many
ways invisible to us.
And they’re already having a real impact
on how people are being assessed, and the
sort of impacts that they might experience
just walking around the city in a day.
So, I think we are coming up with things that
would’ve been great to have, and would still
be useful in some context, but they don’t
resolve, I think, these much bigger questions
around, what is agency, when you’re really
just a point amongst many, many other data
points and being used by a whole range
of systems that are in many ways
completely opaque to you?
I think we need to do a lot more work.
And certainly, I would agree with you.
I mean, this is an urgent area for research.
We just desperately need more people working
in these areas, both technically and I think
on these more social science perspectives.
Host: You know, it’s funny as you’re speaking,
Kate, you actually just identified basically
a generation skip, as it were.
You know like if a country doesn’t have
landline phone infrastructure and goes straight
to cell phones, right?
And so just when we’re thinking we ought
to be more cognizant about giving consent
to apps and technologies, you’re bringing
up the excellent point that there’s so much
going on that we don’t even
get asked for consent.
Kate Crawford: Absolutely. And also,
I mean, there’s another thing here.
I think that we’ve really moved beyond the
discussion of, you know, the idea of a single
person, you know, looking at an app and deciding
whether or not you should allow it to have
access to all of your contacts.
We’re in a very different state where you
could be using an app or system and you’re
thinking that it’s for one thing but it’s
actually doing something else.
I mean, the classic case here is say, you
know, sort of, the Pokémon Go craze where
you are out to sort of catch little Pokémons in a
sort of augmented reality environment in cities.
But that became… or was being used to harvest
a massive training data set to really generate
sort of new maps and geo-locative data.
So, people, in some ways, think that they’re
doing one thing, but their data is being used
to train a completely different type of system
that, you know, they may have no idea about.
So, I think, again, this idea that we’re
even aware of what we’re participating in,
I think, has really moved on.
Host: Yeah, again with the idea that we’re
on a podcast and no one can see me shaking
my head. This does bring up questions about the practical potential solutions that we have.
Is there any, from your end, any recommendation,
not just about what the problems are, but
who should be tackling them and how, I mean…
Kate Crawford: Yeah, absolutely.
I’m actually, I mean, for a while, while
our conversation does cover some really thorny
and I think, you know, quite confronting questions
that we’re going to need to contend with
as researchers and as an industry, I think
that there’s also a lot of hope and there’s
a lot that we can do.
One of the things that I work on at the AI
Now institute is we release an annual State
of AI report. And in that report, we make
a series of recommendations every year.
And in the last report, which just came out
a couple of months ago, we really sort of
made some very clear and direct recommendations
about how to address some of these core problems.
One of them is we just think that before releasing
an AI system, particularly in a high-stakes
domain, so, all of those things we’ve chatted
about like, you know, healthcare, criminal
justice, education, that companies should
be running rigorous pre-release trials to
ensure that those systems aren’t going to
amplify, you know, errors and biases.
And I see that as a fairly basic request.
I mean it’s certainly something we expect
of pharmaceutical drugs before they go on
the market. That they’ve been tested,
that they won’t cause harm.
The same is true of, you know, consumer devices.
Ideally, they don’t blow up, you know,
with some exceptions.
You really want to make sure that there’s
some pretty extensive testing and trials.
And then trials that can be sort of publicly-shared.
That we can say that we have assessed that
this system, you know, doesn’t produce disparate
impact on different types of communities.
I think it’s also really important that
another recommendation, another thing we can
do is, you know, after releasing these sorts
of complex, often, you know, algorithmically-driven
systems, um, should I say, that we just continue
to monitor their use across different contexts
and communities.
Often, a type of system is released, and it’s
assumed that it’s just going to work for
everybody for an indefinite period of time.
It’s just not the case.
I was looking at a study recently that suggested
that medical health data has a 4-month half-life.
That’s 4 months before it becomes out-of-date,
before the data in that training data set
is actually going to become contradicted by
things that have happened after the fact.
So, we need to keep thinking about,
how long is a system relevant?
How might it be performing differently for
different communities?
So, this is another recommendation that we
feel very strongly about.
But there are many more, and if people are
interested in particular types of research
questions or concrete steps that we can take
moving forward, the AI Now 2017 report has
a lot of those in there for more reading.
Host: Yeah.
I would actually encourage our listeners to
get it, and read it, because it is fascinating,
and it addresses things from a, sort of, an
upstream point-of-view, which is I think where
we need to go.
We’re a bit downstream.
Because we’ve released the Kraken,
in many ways, of AI.
It’s like suddenly they’re… in fact,
back to the original… you know the last
18 months, I think part of the reason, maybe,
that we’re seeing an increased interest
is because people are realizing, “Hey this
is happening, and it’s happening to me,
and now I care!”
Prior to that, I just kind of went along and
didn’t pay attention.
So, attention is a good thing.
Let me ask you this.
You mentioned a concept from architecture
called “desire lines” in a talk that I
heard, and I loved it in the sense that it’s
like shortcuts in public spaces, where, you
know, you find a path on the grass just because
people don’t want to go around on the concrete.
And I would say things like Napster and BitTorrent
are sort of examples of technical desire lines,
where it’s like I’m going to go around.
Is there anything in that space that’s sort
of happening now from a grassroots perspective,
where we’re sort of “take back the night”
kind of thing, in the AI world?
Kate Crawford: Yes, I love this.
You know, I think there is.
There are some really nice examples of very
small grassroots efforts that have been extremely
successful in doing things like essentially,
creating spaces of anonymity where you’re
much more protected from your data being harvested,
for reasons that you may or may not have agreed to.
Even things like the private messaging service
signal, which again was created really by
you know, one guy and a few of his friends.
Moxie Marlinspike has been I think very much
a champion that individuals can you know,
create these types of systems that can create
more freedom and more agency for people.
And there are others, too.
I think it’s going to be interesting to think about
how that will happen in an AI-driven world.
And even, I think, in the major technology
companies, I think it’s really important
to create ways that people can start to shape
these tools in the way that they’d most
like to use them, and to give some space for
sort of desire lines where you can say, well
I don’t actually want my AI system to work
this way, or I don’t want it to have access
to this information.
But how can I train it to do what I want it
to do, to make it an advocate for me.
So, rather than serving the interests of,
you know, just a particular company, it’s
really there as my agent, as someone who’s
going to look out for things that I care about.
These are things that we can
think of as design principles.
And certainly, something that people do talk
about a lot at Microsoft Research.
And it’s something that, I think, is really exciting
and inspiring for more work to happen now.
Host: I can’t agree more.
It feels like there’s a “call” both
to the technical designers and makers,
and the end users that need to say
hey, I need to pay attention.
I just can’t be lazy.
I need to take agency.
Kate Crawford: I think that’s
absolutely right.
Host: Kate, before we go, what thoughts or
advice would you leave with our listeners,
many of whom are aspiring researchers, that
might have an interest in the social impact of AI.
I would say go broad on this for both computer
scientists, social scientists, any kind of,
you know… the interdisciplinary crowd.
Kate Crawford: Wow.
Well, first of all, I’d say, welcome!
You’re actually asking some of the most
important questions that can be asked right
now in the research world.
And it would be amazing to see people really
start to dig into specific domain questions,
specific tools, and really start to say, you
know, what kind of world do we want to be
living in, and how can our
tools best serve us there?
In terms of resources that you can go to now,
there really are some great conferences.
Even the big you know, machine-learning conferences
like NIPS have workshops focused on things
like fairness and accountability.
We have the FAT/ML conference which is annual.
But there’s also, you know, the AI Now conferences
which happen every year.
And a lot of, I think, discussion that’s
been happening in a series of groups and reading
groups in various cities that people can connect with.
And I just think there’s like a thriving
research community now that I’m certainly
starting to see grow very rapidly because
these questions are so pressing.
So, in essence, I’d say regardless of your
field, AI is going to be changing the way
we think and work.
And that means that, likely if you’re a
researcher, this is something that you want
to start caring about.
And please, if there are ways that I can help
or if people want to get in touch, they are
welcome to do so.
Host: Kate Crawford, thank you for taking
time out of your schedule.
Like I said, I want to keep
talking to you forever.
Kate Crawford: Such a pleasure.
Thank you so much, Gretchen.
It was great.
Host: To learn more about Dr. Kate Crawford’s
work on the social impacts of AI, and to download
the most recent report from AI Now, visit
Microsoft.com/research.
(music)